[Music]  love is patient love is kind love is not  rude  it doesn't boast love also if it gets  wrong how do it's been hard  hasn't it let go of a prayer for you  don't okay just a sweet word you know  it's okay if you're not sable is prepare  food I'm trying to give you the tools to  succeed and this world is not easy out  there  everything I do this via everything  I know you're under a lot of press right  now but I'm just getting really scared  this place  everything's gonna be okay right  we're in this together  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  you're able you need  trying to hold this family together  [Music]  lord knows I bailed on to way too much  weight in my life  all we have is love  all we have is now  [Music]